developers have strong opinions when it
comes to things like performance and
optimization so when it came time for me
to launch a series I wanted to get
involved in something non-controversial
something that we as programmers all
agree on without hard feeling or rancor
now if I know anything it's that like
operating systems Star Wars versus Star
Trek and how to pronounce gif
you'll never find two engineers arguing
over the ideal developer tools and
development environments take Cortland
here when using C++ cult-like CIN Ian
uses Emacs but there's still great
friends in Android tool time I'll be
exploring the world of Android developer
tools I'll focus on address studio
checking out new tools undiscovered
features pro tips and get expert advice
directly from the Android studio team
and of course we'll go in-depth into
each new release of Android studio
including finding out what's in this
entirely nondescript and non ominous box
I'm reto Meier join me on the Android
developers YouTube channel as we talk
developer tools the least controversial
topic in computer science
it's and ER at all time time